in our planned expenditure model we've
been we've been assuming that planned
investment is fixed and what i want to
do in this video is think about how real
interest rates how real interest rates
drive
how they drive planned investment or
another think about the function
investment as a function of real
interest rates planned investment as a
function of real interest rates and when
i'm talking about real interest rates
i'm really just talking about nominal
interest rates factoring out or
discounting what's going on with
inflation and there's other videos where
we go into more depth on that another
way to think about if there were no
inflation real and nominal interest
rates would be the same thing and i want
to tackle it with a very a very tangible
example so let's say in this upcoming
year there's a bunch of potential
planned projects so let's call this so
let's call this so projects so these are
really potential investments so you have
projects and then you have some level of
expected return so each of the people
who are thinking about these projects
they all have their spreadsheets out and
they've taken in risk and probabilities
and all of the rest and they've come up
with their expected return numbers and
let's say project a has an expected
return of 20
b
c
i'll do a couple more d 10
e is 5
and then f is let's say f is two percent
and let's say initially let's say in one
state of affairs interest rates are
relatively high so let's say r1 is equal
to 19
interest rates so if 19 if we have 19
real interest rates and these are the
real expected returns which of these
projects will actually be invested in
which of the ones will people actually
do
well if someone has the cash they say
well i could either i could either lend
my money out for nineteen percent or i
could do this project and get twenty
percent so if they have the cash they
would definitely do this and if they
don't have the cash they could say well
i could borrow money for nineteen
percent and i can invest it at twenty
percent i'll make money off of that so
project a
project a will definitely be done now
what about project b well project b if
the person actually has the cash on hand
to do project b they say well i could do
project b and get an 18 real return or i
could lend that money out and get a 19
real return so actually i would not do
project b and obviously i would not do
anything with that has an even lower
real return and if i wanted if i could
potentially do project b but i had to
borrow the money well if i had to borrow
the money at 19
real interest and i'm only getting 18 on
it that's a money losing proposition so
i wouldn't do b and i definitely
wouldn't do all of these things that get
a lower return
so when i have when i have high interest
rates right over here the only thing i
would do is project a project
project a now let's think about what
would happen if interest rates went down
if real interest rates went down so
let's say real interest rate let's call
that r2
let's call that r2 real interest rates
go down to
and let's say they go down to three
percent
well once again project a you are
definitely going to do if you have the
money on hand you get 20 doing project a
you definitely don't wanna lend it out
at three percent if you don't have the
money on hand you can borrow it three
percent and invest it twenty percent and
so by the same logic people would do
project b you could borrow it three
percent and and and make eighteen
percent or if you have the money you get
18 versus 3 on your money so you
definitely do this you do all of these
up to you would even do project e if you
have the money you would rather
put that money and get 5 then lend it
out and only get percent so you'll even
do project e if you need to borrow it it
still makes sense borrow money at three
percent invested at five percent you're
making some real return the only one
that you would not do is project f right
over here because here you aren't
actually covering your cost of borrowing
if you had to borrow three percent and
invest it two percent doesn't make sense
if you have the money you would rather
lend your money out at three percent
than do project f so you're definitely
not going to do you're definitely not
going to do f in this scenario and
actually obviously do it in neither
scenario so right over here
you do all of the above so you would do
a
b
c
d not all of the above all of the above
except for f a b c d and e so let's just
think about the rough level of
investment so if we were to plot
if we were to plot on this axis right
over here
if we were to plot the
relative less investment as a function
of real interest rates and over here we
actually have real we actually have the
the
the independent variable is our real
interest rate at a high real interest we
had a low level of investment we only
did project a so that's right over there
that is a
only so this is when we were at r1 and
then when we lowered interest rates
to r2 we had a much higher level of
investment we did all of these projects
right over here so you had a much higher
level of investment so this is a b
c
d
and e and so you see that you have an
inverse relationship the lower the real
interest rate the more investment that's
going to go on the higher the interest
rate the less investment that goes on
and you can debate whether it's a curve
or a line but for sake of simplicity
we'll assume that it looks something
that it looks something like
it looks i need to draw i'll draw a
dotted line it's easier for me to do
that it might look something like that
and now we can use this insight to start
thinking about how a change in real
interest rate might shift our planned
expenditures on our keynesian cross and
from that we can start to think about
the is curve the famous is curve in the
islm model